The final question I have for you is, have you lowered your level
of confidence that they deserved it after this conversation?
>> Okay, I'll answer that directly. No. And be [laughter]
>> dude, no shot. Oh, get me out. Get me out. Get me out.
Get me out. Get me out. Get me out. Thank god the stream's at
zero. I can't go a lot longer. Okay. Holy [__] I'm
confident in my assessment of the stuff I have seen, you know,
just
[music]
>> I [music] want to watch that pisco conversation with
this Jedi person. Okay. I want to watch that that conversation
that I've heard is really good. It's really funny. You are you
are so saying he is hypocritical for not going after XC, but
he is not. No, he's saying he's lying. I mean, he's saying he's
lying. Based on that rationale, he would be hypocritical, but
he doesn't have that rationale. Obviously, he doesn't have the
rationale that he is protecting copyright. He's going after people
he doesn't like, obviously. >> What up, Jedi? >> Anyway,
we have Jedi here with Pisco. Let's check it out. >> Uh,
can you hear me? >> Yeah. What up, bro? >> Uh, I
I I disagree about a different thing. I agree with you 100%.
Uh well, a different thing regarding this specific issue, but
um I agree. The people that are saying this is about setting
some sort of legal precedent or protecting React or any of that
stuff, they're just coping. They're stupid. They're coping.
They're idiots. >> Appreciate it. Okay.
>> It's obviously true that what this is is
he was setting a trap. It was a dirty >> and he was setting
it to exact consequences on people who he believes wronged them.
>> The thing I disagree with is I think that's a good thing.
>> Okay, let's talk about that. >> Good that he did
that. >> All right, let's talk about it. >> I uh
>> I mean I it was a dirty trick. I will admit it's dirty
trick. It is not what the law is ideally supposed to be used
for. It probably sets a bad precedent in the sense that rich
people trample on poor people. judgment proof people etc. Um
but I think
on the other hand
uh Lox I was watching Loner Box earlier today and he had some
good analogies that I think were kind of apt. So I'm just going
to steal one. Some basically like you got
>> Wait, what? Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. What do you mean
that's a good thing? The [__] do you mean that's
a good
Wait, what?
Yeah, I understand. It leads to like all of the worst things
for any online commentary, but I think that's a good thing, actually.
Huh?
Wait, that's that's maybe the most absurd position I've ever
seen. At least on its face. But maybe this guy cooks. He says
he learned this from Loner Box. Can I find the lonerbox section
on this? Is there a lonerbox section,
bro? Somebody go find the lonerbox timestamp where he says anything
like what this guy's saying.
>> That's crazy.
>> lonerbox. Lonerbox has to sue this guy for defamation.
Lonerbox Loner Box be like, "Dude, that's so
that's that's so defamatory." So Lerbox has suffered actual harm
for this guy uttering his name while giving this level of take
>> using um
>> unconventional
weaponry. And you can't use conventional weaponry against them.
Actually, I think he used the Gaza example, which is kind of
>> Oh, like if if terrorists are doing this, you you can't
>> Listen, if terrorists are going to put a bunch of little
kids around their rocket platforms, okay, you kind of just have
to blow up those little kids. It's like that's just how it is,
man. What are you supposed to just let a like a $100,000 Iron
Dome missile intercept that rocket? No shot. No way. establish
rules of the road if if both parties aren't adhering to them,
right? >> I don't think that was actually said. It's just
a joke. >> Just a joke. >> Something like that.
>> Kind of like like like imagine, you know, the I mean
what people are saying justifies stuff Israel does, which is
like these people are firing little
>> Okay, never mind. That's like exactly what the argument
was.
Ah,
I really feel like Come on. No. No, that wouldn't have happened.
That couldn't have possibly happened. I don't believe it. I don't
believe it. Okay. I don't believe that's true. >> From
fortified bunkers and yeah, their rockets aren't doing much.
They're getting intercepted by Iron Dome. They're not really
a super big threat, but for Israel to I'm not saying by this
analogy, but I'm just saying it's an analogy. Um,
for Israel to respond, they have to use an overwhelming sort
of response. They have to use like a 2,000 lb. You would you
bunker buster? >> Would you say something like this? So
So let me see if I get the analogy correct and then we can get
to the actual thing. So let's say which I grant is violating
international law and targeting civilians which they do, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. But >> okay. So I just want
to be clear. >> I should say I'm just using the analogy.
I understand. So the thinking >> So you think the analogy
is apt and convincing, right? You're not just saying that it's
an analogy that you're expressing. It's one that convinced you,
right? [laughter] Listen, I didn't say it. I just heard it and
I was like that seems really good. I'm not saying I agree with
it. I just like it. It sounded really good and like it seemed
like a way I could just totally not care about this stupid fat
Caseyron. So I I wanted to present it to you. Is this a way I
can not care about this stupid fat Caseyron? Guys, Pisco, please
give me my blessing so I can just hate this stupid fat and and
revel in her downfall. Please, please.
>> Did it convince her not? Sorry. Sorry. I just want to
get clarity. Did the analogy convince you or not? >> That's
that's a fantastic way I I feel like this is something Pisco
has to do because of how people argue on his stream. Like people
really do show up to Pisco's stream and they'll do like the oh,
I was just saying this and other people said this, but I don't
believe it. Dude, nothing more frustrating when that happens,
man. Uh, actually, I was just presenting somebody else's argument.
I don't necessarily believe it at all. If you don't make that
very clear before you start arguing. Holy >> Okay. Yeah.
>> Um I was already convinced, but if I wasn't, it would
have. >> You found it to be something that you found. Okay.
>> And so they now >> I I'm just totally correct.
Do you hear that? It sounded I was already convinced, but it
sounded like something that would convince me to
>> you would agree targets Israeli civilians. Correct.
In war crimes. >> Yeah. that justifies Israel targeting
um civilians with war crimes in Gaza. >> Oh, no, no, no,
no, no. >> Oh, no, no, no. Why not? Why not? That >> that's
that's not the the analogy. The analogy is that they're targeting
civilians. It's that
according to Israel, the justification they use is
>> in order to >> and they use that justification
to explain what what is the ultimate unfurling of that justification?
What has it led to? What can you understand like why we might
not want to use the Israeli justification for the entire Gaza
operation as our modus operandi in any other field? Because it's
clearly in terms of the actual end state, it's disastrous. to
get to these people making pot shots because of the way they're
positioning themselves.
We have to use over force that has the consequence as a, you
know, as a collateral damage thing of doing massive damage and
and >> dude, there's no way there's no shot.
>> While adhering while adhering to certain principles.
Correct.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. They're not just outright doing super
war because they're not like nuking Gaza to get to these people.
They're not using chemical weapons to get to these people, but
they are using means that will kill
>> But within >> and the only war crimes are nukes
or chemical weapons
on your within the rules of war. Correct. Not outside the rules
of war, right? >> Yeah. I guess the analogy breaks down
>> Yeah. So, so but let's actually go to the actual thing.
>> Sure. Sure. But yeah. Yeah. But the the point the point
I'm saying is that yes, this is a dirty trick. It it was a dirty
trick. It is
>> okay. I'm just going to say it. When this guy popped
on the stream and was like, "Ethan Klein's a filthy duplicitous
Jew that is using tactics." I personally would have disavowed
that immediately. Pisco, on the other hand, he's just going to
let that slide. His hatred for Israel really knows no bounds.
Okay. I I think this guy when he keeps saying it's a dirty, filthy
trick, I would personally check that. But I understand Piscos.
He's a little upset with some of the people been coming on to
argue. It's a little weird, but okay. To each his own. All right.
See you, Koko. Have a good law ought to be used. And if it's
if it sets a a precedent in the direction of
rich people just crouching on poor people, that's a bad
>> I don't. But hold on. The non-legal precedent that has
been set is there is a way that you can enforce your copyright
without DMCA that automatically if the person has done something
wrong with your copyright, they can automatically be sued and
and harmed like significantly. And by the way, this affects in
essence through the Denim's lawsuit every single person who reacts,
right? The Denims lawsuit is not in terms of the actual copyright
statute
like differentiable from XQC doing his reaction except that it's
better like Denims transforms more. Denims is less of a market
replacement. Denims doesn't upload to YouTube a really big YouTube
channel with the same title essentially the same thumbnail essentially.
She's like better if Denims can be sued for her reaction with
the same precedent like with the same way in the same way and
she's forced to pay all this money to legal towards lawyers to
deal with it. I think Yeah. Yeah. It's game over for everybody
who's like critical of other people's content and reacts to like
full videos. It's super game over. >> Precedent. But I
think the actual precedent, not legal precedent, but like cultural
precedent that I hope it sets and I think it will is
don't participate in organized harassment campaigns against people.
>> All right. >> Because you might [clears throat]
get >> Okay. So, okay.
All right. This is Uhhuh. Oh man, I just organized harassment
campaigns.
Can we find like what's the worst thing Casey Tron did? What's
the worst thing she did to Ethan? What's the worst thing she
said about Ethan? I actually don't know. I would love to know
because you know what I you know what I think happened is I think
somebody basically was watching Alo and Caseyron, okay, and saw
her say something like weird or or rude about Ethan and probably
just sent it to Ethan immediately. And it's like dude, do we
have like realistically she's a really small streamer. She's
got no pull. Are we Why Why are we acting like she did something
horrible here? Like she was a sign significant part of anything
like a harassment campaign.
I just don't see it, man. I don't see it. I I really >> Let's
get to the actual facts. So,
>> Casey Tron deserves
this dirty trick because >> because she
thank God. Okay, Pisco is learning how to argue with these people,
right? He's learning how to He's learning the golem tactics.
The golems roll up repeatedly and they they say the most and
he's just like, "Wait, why do you think that? Wait, how do you
think that? That's like the first question. It's just like, can
you show me that you've done the bare minimum? You've invested
the bare minimum in learning something about this situation so
that you can not be when you talk to me. Have you done anything?
Have you done any work? Do you care at all? Or are you just going
to say things that make you feel good without understanding where
they come from at all? And then you'll you'll do that and you'll
never say, "Well, I'm saying this with no proof. It's just how
I feel." You won't say that when you say it. You'll say the thing
like you know it, like you believe it and then when somebody
checks you, you go, "Well, I really didn't know." Okay. Why are
you Why are you misrepresenting it? Why are you saying you know
this totally >> was um Okay, I will say two things. She
may or may not deserve
everything about this for her particular quote unquote crimes.
I don't mean legal crimes, but
I like realistically
can I just go try to find some like Casey if I just search YouTube
YouTube.com you know who would know this is like Willy Mack I
bet you I could go to Willie's channel and Willie Mac would know
right so we go Caseyron Ethan Klein
um
Jesus Christ DK's going off with those with those thumbnails
like what did what did she do one day ago 16 I'm going to find
everything like the old the newer videos right I did a protection
spell for my lawsuit against Ethan Klein, it didn't work. Casey,
Casey, I'm here from the future to tell you it didn't work. Casey,
what to do >> And the ritual didn't work. Casey,
>> I don't know what's happening with the video, but but
Casey, it didn't work. It didn't work, Casey. No, Casey.
>> Wait, wait, wait. I'm just gonna ask >> I just
want to know like what the worst thing she said was. What the
did she say? If you do before xxx, YouTube should generally pull
stuff from uh at and before the day. Wait, is it like uh year
month day format before
Wait, is it dashes 1204
2025? Let's Let's do this. Day, month, year. Day, month, year.
Oh, I'll have to do 11.
11 actually 10. We'll do 10
Okay, it is getting me stuff from way. No, 13 hours ago. Before
2023.
No, no, no.
Whatever. Uh, I'll figure it out at some >> It's fine.
It's fine. I Why did I put it into this video? I used my targets
Israeli civilian
>> because she was
um Okay, I will say two things. She may or may not deserve
everything about this for her
>> But yeah, the whole thing I need to know is like what
the did she do? What the did she say that makes it so she deserves
to be totally? She deserves to be totally financially dominated
and decide between total humiliation on the internet or losing
her house and and making her parents homeless. Like what was
the thing she said? Because we all, by the way, everybody acknowledges
this. This acknowledges this. Now, you think she deserves it
because of what she said, right? So, what did she say? I'll I'll
even say, okay, let's go past the point of like, clearly Ethan
wasn't doing this to protect copyright. Clearly, he wasn't doing
it for anything like that. He was just trying to hurt people
who hurt him, right? What did she say that hurt him so badly
that this was the appropriate response? >> Quote unquote
crimes. I don't mean legal crimes, wrongdoing.
But >> wait, wait, hold. I'm just going to ask the question.
Are you sure or are you not sure that she deserves a dirty trick?
Casey Tron >> in case Trump in particular. >> Are
you sure or not sure? >> I don't know if
Well, that's a hard moral calculus. I mean, I'm >> I don't
I don't know if
anyone in particular deserves to be potentially made homeless
and their family for even for participating in an organized harassment
campaign. I don't know. >> Wait, what what do you take
to be >> She did she participate in harassment? >> Yeah,
she was basically part of the whole ring. an organized harassment
ring of people who spent like a year or longer going after
>> wasn't Casey Tron. Yeah, Casey is totally guilty of
copyright infringement.
That's not why she was sued at all.
Right. It's like transparently not why she was sued. It's transparently
not what this is about.
She is totally guilty of copyright infringement. Yes, she's a
total loser. She's not a content creator who transforms anything
ever. She's total [__] loser. Okay, but that's not
what she was sued for. And we've moved way past that. We we understand
that that Ethan was not trying to protect copyright because he's
also suing Denims and none of that applies to denims. So I'm
telling you that clearly he's just doing this. He's suing people
who have upset him, who have talked about him. And I'm trying
to figure out what they did. What did they participate in? What
was their participation? What did it look like that they deserve
all of this negative attention? All these negative financial
consequences. That's what I want to know. harassment ring of
people who spent like a year or longer going after him. You know,
the skulls, the the
>> Wait, she she was parting so she >> she's a part
of doxing and skulls. Doxing and skulls.
This guy can't even >> Bro, it's like actually they've
regressed so badly that they can't even say like, "Oh, it was
the they she sent like skulls or she, you know, had people in
her community." Dude, it's all the same webbing from these communities
that were the only vanguard against it on the internet. It's
so disappointing. It's such a fall from grace, right? Destiny's
community was the community that that produced the Keles manifesto
and was like, "Actually, this webbing is totally you can't just
say people are connected and then blame the worst the the better
person, the person who's acts at a higher degree, a higher moral
standard. You can't blame them for everything the worst person
does. You can't take some tangential connection and do that.
It's nuts, right? And this is the one community that was like
trying to stand on it apparently, but apparently it was only
because it was happening to Destiny. Nothing about it was a principled
stance. It was just, "Oh, it's wrong to do this to Destiny only."
For everybody else, it's totally fine. >> It's such Ethan.
Did she do Ethan? >> Do you have any evidence she do? >> I
don't know if she did. >> I don't have any evidence on.
>> Uh, do you have any evidence that she participate? Wait,
wait, wait. Let's just go through it. Did you have any evidence
that she participated that she participated in the skull? Nope.
Do you have By the way, this is just exactly what Destiny's community
does to mine, right? It's the exact same thing. And it's the
exact same response and the exact same total
slack jaw stare that I know this guy's throwing into his monitor
right now. Like, uh, no, I actually can't prove anything. And,
uh, um, no, I know I look like a total for saying it. Uh, but
I'm going to say it still, actually. Yeah, that's how it's going
to be. have any evidence that she participated in harassment?
By which I mean an infringement on someone's personal privacy
or um putting them in fear >> using a legal definition.
No, but in the colloquial sense. Yes. >> In what?
Okay. Dude, this I don't know. This guy hasn't identified that
he's coping and he is coping. He's in a cope spiral right now.
Look, listen. No, not like not legally. Probably you couldn't
like sue her for it, but like Colloquially, I think she's responsible.
Okay, how? Bro, stop. Just admit you're just admit you've you've
had your gaped open on a stream. You don't know what you're talking
about. You're incapable of defending your ideas. Okay, just say
it. Just tap out. Say uncle. That's all you got to do. Say uncle.
>> Sense that she engaging harassment. >> I'm I mean,
I don't have clips to bring up, but I think everyone just kind
of >> Yeah. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. Don't try
to pull that. Oh, Pisco asked me for a clip directly. That's
so bad faith. No, he didn't. Just say what you think she did.
Say what you think she did. How she participated. Say what you
think. Cuz you don't think. You have no thoughts in that big
dumb mug of yours. So shut the up and don't go around spreading
about people that you have no idea about. Okay. How about you
stop talking? It's super easy. Hey, I want to say something that
is a like an actual allegation of somebody doing really harmful
things. Do I know that they did that? Can I say what they actually
did? No. Okay, shut the up. Super easy. Super easy. >> Oh,
she did it. >> What would you characterize? Wait, wait.
So, let me just clear, >> dude. He You hear it. You hear
the like cognitive dissonance. You hear this total blank black
hole in his head. He's speaking and you hear the emptiness. You
can hear it in his voice. I
know. I don't know. But she I I know she said it. I know she
said it. >> I'm I mean I don't have clips to bring up,
but I think everyone just kind of knows she did it. >> What
would you characterize? Wait, so let me So So maybe
as
>> for for people who say they hate Mao, they hate communism,
they hate re-education. They sure do love participating as actual
re-educated people, don't they? Don't they folks? is people with
absolutely no liberty, no no liberal processes in their mind.
They're just totally brainwashed communist bots. Okay, how sorry
to the communist in chat. I know you guys like communism stuff,
but they are like actually re-educated total bots. They're in
a cult. It's so embarrassing.
And by the way, I'm sitting here and I'm like, I do think Casey
said some things that seem a little like deranged, like they
were probably over the line probably.
But I wouldn't go and say, "Oh, Casey Tron like doxes people."
and have no idea of who she who she'd done it to or what she'd
actually done. I I would have I would need some understanding
of like why I'm making that allegation, right? Has to be tied
to something. Even if it's not a clip, even if it's just you
saying, "Yeah, well, she actually said that when when Ethan had
the CPS call happen, she was like, "Oh, it definitely he deserved
that 100%." Like, that would be a start at least.
No, that would be a start, but this guy can't even get there.
As you s as you as you sit here, what is the worst act that Casey
Tron that you know that she did against
>> Oh, dude, I have like the exact dialed in instincts
that Pisco does. Like I see maybe u actually this honestly this
guy might be dumb enough that maybe just everybody can see exactly
where you would go here, but I I just feel like I I ask a question
and Pisco knows that's the most important question right now.
You love to see it. H God, you know, I'm not super versed on
the lore in >> So, as you sit here, are you sure? So, so
as so as you sit here, are you sure she deserved this, in your
words, dirty
>> Oh, I just noticed I just noticed Queen and Straighter
in the chat over here. How you love to see it. Yeah, I can see
it. Oh, boy. Oh, no. Oh, no. Oh, no.
Um, as I sit here, I take I should say I took it or I take it
because I continue to take it on the good faith of the word of
some others that I trust.
>> I want this person. Okay, listen to what he's saying.
Is it any shock that this dude is a total Zogbot, too? Anybody
shocked about that? Right. I take it on good faith that this
person who has never acted in good faith in their entire career
is telling me the truth. That's what I do.
Holy [__] I Dude, there's no way. This guy has to
be someone who's from this who's in this community at some point,
too, right? Hold on. Hold on. Let me see. Do I go for this name
anywhere? Oh, yeah. I do.
They're in the Discord as of
six months ago. Yeah, as of six months
I think they were an actual participant for quite a while here.
Yeah, they they were calling in in April. Apparently, they called
in in April. I wonder what they called in about. I moved them
in.
How long were they calling in for? 2 minutes. Oh, not very long.
3 minutes. Too bad.
>> Perhaps she did.
>> Oh, wait. That's last year. Holy, that's a long time
ago. Yeah. So, definitely a DGR. You take it on good faith that
she
who's who are you giving the good faith to here? >> Who
are we giving Who are we giving the good faith to?
I take it on good faith that she definitely deserved this. She
definitely deserved Ethan Klein saying dance spin in circles
and say I'm a good little piggy or else I'm going to take your
parents house away. That's what she deserved. Okay. And I'm going
to take it on good faith that she deserved it cuz realistically
I need to believe that. >> Okay. A lot of our knowledge
is we don't A lot of the knowledge we have doesn't come firsthand.
It comes through >> how dare you. So you're sitting here
and you're care [laughter]
a lot of the knowledge we have we have does doesn't come firsthand.
Yeah. Sure. Like the things you do to make the use to make decisions,
but you don't go and say this is true on a stream. You're like
literally coming on this stream to say no, no, no. I think this
is the way the world is. You're coming on to advocate for something.
Nobody advocates for things on good faith. You're a total [__]
if you think that. Oh, I'm gonna go on a stream and I'm gonna
advocate for some position or something some, you know, statement
specifically in based on good faith that somebody else was telling
the truth. That's my only source. Somebody else told me it and
I believe they were acting in good faith. Shut the up. Characterizing
something as a dirty trick that it was it was something that
in general is wrong. You characterize it similar to Israel and
whereby you're saying well overwhelming forces needed against
Yeah. No, you but you found it convincing. I asked you that question
and you're analogizing it to Israel. >> Let's be real.
Let's be real.
There isn't a better analogy, is there? That's like the best
analogy they could have done, isn't it? That's like actually
it's like the perfect analogy. It like couldn't be a better analogy.
It's just like so on the nose directly. Thank you so much for
using that analogy specifically. Holy [__] >> In
that Israel's overwhelming force is justified based on some horrible
thing that uh is doing or some intrigence by which this kind
of thing is a merited response. And you sit here and you say
you cannot explain a single concrete thing that you think is
beyond the pale for which this kind of reaction would be deserved.
I'm not saying it's not, by the way. I'm just saying as you sit
here, you're willing to judge her as deserving of a dirty trick
without having any knowledge as to the the concrete thing she
does to merit it. >> I I don't have specific dates and
clips in mind, but I have seen videos in and I can go back and
rewatch. >> What do you recall? They What? What do you
recall? They contained that case. Yes. Yes. Yes. Literally, I
I'm not asking you for a specific clip. Just point me in a direction.
Give me any any glimmer of hope that you are a human being and
not a disgusting brainwashed bot freak. ANYTHING.
ANYTHING. GIVE ME ANYTHING, PLEASE.
>> Give me anything.
>> anything, please. >> I don't remember. I She's
not that important. I don't really think about her, but I know
I know for one thing. I mean, it's not >> I don't really
think about her, but I know this deserved it. I don't really
think about her, but I know this dumb fat [__] deserved
>> it. This, but she maliciously lied about
>> uh [clears throat] actually I don't really care. Actually,
I
actually you're not really important to me. That's that person's
not important to me. You came on a stream specifically to argue
that she deserves something and then your response after getting
your ass blown out is, "Oh, I don't even care about that stupid
bitch." Good one. >> Loner box. I know that. But other
than that, specifically, she
again. Lonerbox,
lonerbox, answer for your community member. Loner box, answer
for this total [__] >> I know for one thing,
I mean, it's not really important to this, but she maliciously
lied about Loner Box. I know that. But other than that, specifically,
>> oh, she maliciously lied about Loner Box. What did she
say about Loner Box?
Uh, I'll point out if she maliciously lied about a loader box,
it seems like Ethan Klein was getting free concessions from her.
Did he really not include Loner Box in that? He didn't go ahead
and help Lunar Box out or
>> No, no, >> I don't know. But I
>> So she she lied about someone else. >> Well, maliciously
in a way that is sort of uh part of the overall narrative, but
it that doesn't matter that that that the loner box thing doesn't
matter. >> Okay. So, I'll I'll discount it. >> Yes.
Yes. Yes. If you if you are looking for a spec even a specific
single thing I could point to a quote I don't have it. What I
do have is an impression I got through watching various media
clips of her and that I can't recall at the moment. Maybe I could
go back and bring them but they >> No, no, no. I don't
trust me. I don't need a clip from this guy. I just want like
Do you feel like I I Dude, Pisco, help him out. Start giving
him help, man. Did you? Please, please. Uh, did you ever get
back to Lerbox about the guy pedaling Jtock? Oh, um,
no. Well, I mean, Loner Box was just like, I don't know. I basically
said like, do you have any proof of that? And he said no, and
I don't think I can do anything more. And I'm like, well, I feel
like I feel like you it feels better to me if you say like, obviously
that's not true unless you can prove any of it. But it's like
whatever. I What am I going to go like soy rage at Loner Box
about it? I can't do much, right? No, you have to you have to
stand up for me. Load up. It just doesn't it's bad optics. Okay.
Just doesn't look good.
No, you have to more aggressively you have to more aggressively
castrate this guy. The the dude's a total [__]
um hold on, hold on, hold on. What was I about to say? Oh, Pisco
should start helping him out. Pisco should start being like Did
she say like Did she say that like she talked about the sword?
Did she say Did she say that like the sword was like if it wasn't
on sword then Ethan deserved it? Did she like what? There has
to be some pretense for this, right? There has to be something.
>> It cemented the view in my head that she is a bad faith
actor and did enough participation in this campaign that she
is maybe not uh an acceptable specific target, but maybe instrumentally
>> like like collateral damage. I mean, that really would
be a kind of Israel. >> Maybe not. Maybe [laughter]
>> maybe not necessarily collateral because it's not he
went for her specifically, but as an effective means to the ends
of >> has giving has to be really careful because if you
ask these people too many questions, if you bring them on, you
ask them too many questions, they will start to like totally
check out of your stream. They'll really the the cognitive dissonance
will never be overcome by pointing out that they don't have anything
there, right? they will just stop watching. So like it's it's
like damned if you do, damned if you don't sometimes like the
people literally can't handle it. They can't handle it at all.
It's very sad.
It's very very sad. was the some of the biggest figures in this
harassment >> who and again by harassment >> the
real the real point is to go
>> you don't have evidence that she's participated in the
so I I would take like something to be harassment is I so so
I think harassment for example would include sending um imu uh
either
objects or images or something to put someone in fear um intentionally
so I think the skull if he if he was sent skull I would think
that that's harassment if uh you know any kind of fake report
or report based on
Tubby. Too in the chat, too. Tubby says, "Casey's disabled family
members ending up homeless would be justified collateral damage
because she's hiding under them, hiding near them." [laughter]
Casey Trod has a rocket launcher, and the rocket launcher is
her getting super
wasted. Okay, super high. And then going, "Ethan Clyde sucks."
And we have to take that rocket platform out, okay? And if we
have to take our parents house, if we have to make them homeless
to do it, that's okay. That's justified. Okay. That's the Israeli
way. Let's go. >> Lies or something like that. I would
take that to be harassment.
Yeah. So, but the problem is you need to show that she's involved
in that, don't you? >> lying about someone is not harassment.
You agree, right? >> Yeah. It's not. But I think I think
when you um when you have big figures and you have a
how to say it, a one insect biting you isn't a big deal. You
just swat it or you just ignore it. It doesn't hurt you. But
if you have a swarm of bees going after you that even though
each individual bee doesn't mean much, the cumulative effect
when you're like a public figure like Ethan and you have what
happened after the leftovers and that organized harassment campaign
going after him. I if I were in that position and then got skull
sent and had the CPS thing and had endless harassment, >> you
would sue someone that you can't prove as you said here that
was involved in that. You would sue them. >> You would
set a trap for them to sue them. people who you can't prove were
involved in that. >> People who I was confident enough
were involved or even even even somewhat >> this is by
the way I hope you all understand that this is like the rot underlying
the entire like when I it's it sounds schizophrenic but like
Destiny's past year relies on this narrative this level of like
webbing being something you can do reliably and and effectively.
You have to allow this stuff, right? And then on the H3 side,
I don't know what it is, but like it's clear that these things
are related. Okay, I this is this thing I keep referring to that
it sounds schizophrenic to talk about it, right? But it's it's
this same like webbing thing that goes on with my community and
then the H3 community and I guess or sorry, the the H3 snark
type area where people are like, "Oh, Denims is like snark and
Casey is like snark and Shauna Black is like snark." And it's
like, okay, you can't just you can't this isn't the way it works.
And we all agreed this wasn't the way it works three to four
years ago, right? When the ca when the careful happened, we all
stood on business and said, "No, no, no. That's not how this
works." And now somehow it's like the enemies of of
the enemies of certain people, okay? Like Dan and Destiny. Now
they're like, "Oh, no. We have to do this. We have to do this.
We have to do this webbing. This webbing is totally legitimate
and fine and cool."
It's like, dude, what? And the the It's just shocking to watch
the exact thing that was labeled as bad, the worst thing you
could do. This totally disingenuous framing that's just using
like people's reputations, like a bad person's reputation, tying
other people to it. That that kind of thing is the worst thing
you could do because it it totally discounts what somebody's
actual argument is. It's just a way to totally ignore where you
might be wrong. And now they're just using it as a weapon intentionally.
And it's the same thing. Ah, it's so frustrating, man.
>> these people weaken a nod to it. Sure.
>> Yeah, I would. I'd be pissed.
>> No, [laughter] I mean, >> well, while Well, hold
on. While literally participating in communities that Well, hold
on. Maybe this guy Maybe this guy isn't in uh Destiny's chat
anymore. Maybe he doesn't participate directly in communities
that docks people. Although, Dan is a frequent regular on Loterbox's
stream as somebody who docks his people constantly,
right? So, I don't even know. The loner box kind of kind of got
a doxing community at this point, too. If he's going to have
Dan on all the time. Yeah. Let's go. Let's go. Let's take a look.
Let's see. We got anything here? Nope. This person This person
is not in Destiny's community from what I can see. So, okay.
That's Oh, listen. A little a little saved. A little saved. A
little saved. Okay. Look, I don't think he needs to have unearthed,
I don't know, a secret discord ring of of her talking with all
the Splunk mods and all the
>> Do you see Do you see the parallels? Do you see the
exact par? Okay, he's not in the he's not in DG chat, but dude,
the parallel is exact, is it not? I think um actually they've
got a discord where they talk about this and I don't think you
need proof of it. I think you just need the fact that like sometimes
they say the same thing. I think sometimes it's just like they
they talk about the same things. Yeah, those are like total just
totally just facts of reality, but those facts were referenced
by a really bad place and that means the other other people can't
reference them. Okay. The fact that Ethan fed his dog cheese
is not something you can reference because snarkers talked about
it. You can't talk about it cuz Starkers talked about it. It's
not allowed.
No. How about no? How about shut the up
>> people? We're going to get Ethan now. I don't think
that's necessary to justify what he did. I think her being a
public figure and >> Oh, wait, wait, wait. Hold on. Now,
now you don't have to know about any of the harassment to justify
what he did. Wait, I thought that was the entire justification.
That was the entire thing he went with. He's He's decided, listen,
this cope isn't working so well. Okay, this cope was kind of
kind of It wasn't cooked enough. It was a little a little raw
cope and I need to go back to the I need to go back to the drawing
board and come up with a whole different line. So now it doesn't
matter if he can prove that or not doesn't matter. There's something
else. >> I think her being a public figure and lying about
him in ways that sort of feed that narrative and >> so
I'm seeing something in the chat.
>> Okay, so she lied about him in ways that feed that narrative.
Fantastic.
for example, like she called him a Zionist, >> Sure, that's
part of it. But I mean, okay, but if that's the nature of the
>> dude Morgan third, [laughter] dude, Pisco is being gaslit.
Pisco is being gas lit. Pisco is being gas dude is so respectful.
What's the point of raging out? I'm just going to slip on here
and say that this compelled speech thing is so cool because she
deserves it. Um, and I'm saying in a very respectful way. Yeah,
you're saying something disgusting in a very respectful way.
in the exact way I don't respect somebody who comes on and drops
a hard R and says all black people should die in a very respectful
way because listen I listen I'm not saying like all black people
should die I'm just like they should be in their own communities
they shouldn't be around me I just kind of don't really think
they're on the same level as white people and I I just you know
I feel like that's just a normal thing to believe
if you say okay I I went too hard at first but if if somebody
was like that well he said it so respectfully Doesn't sound like
he's married to it. It doesn't sound like he wants to believe
it. And then you like cope around that. What? That's not a respectable.
That's a totally deranged degenerate loser thing to do. It's
disgusting. It is disgusting. Even if you talk very nicely about
something that's disgusting, it's still disgusting. and my ability
to identify the abstract concepts you're hinting at, the thing
you're actually talking about and dis and totally disconnect
it from your tone and go, regardless of the tone you say this
in, it's a stupid thing to say that you should know is stupid.
You should actually be chastised for saying this, right? Anyway,
what's up, Lav?
Okay. Uh, do I cover up for stuff Lav says? Lav says deranged
things all the time. Yeah, hold on. You understand that? My whole
point here is what did Casey say that's so crazy that she that
she like literally can't um that she deserves to be like doxed
or sued or have her house threatened to compel her speech to
to give up on some drama.
That's what we're talking about here,
My position would be that's crazy to do just like it would be
crazy to do to laugh for some crazy thing she said, right? I
don't know
>> that the nature by the lie about what we're talking
about. This this is just this is total gaslighting. This is crazy.
First of all, I think he buys >> Also, real quick, Pisco
is like the principal guy, right? He's the guy who gets mad.
>> If that is the nature by the li we're talking about.
First of all, I think he by his own by his own lights, he would
be considered a Zionist. if he believes in the establishment
of a state in in Palestine, doesn't that definitionally, if you're
committed to that as an ide ideological matter, regardless of
whether he's a liberal Zionist or someone who believes that there's
genocide going on, wouldn't he definitionally be a Zionist on
that >> Of course. Yeah, of course he is. Yeah. I mean,
he's Zionist. A lot of people are Zionist. >> So, I I'm
not even sure that's untrue. And then, uh, secondly, >> of
course, it's not untrue.
>> Is there a line where it's okay for Ethan to do what
he did? Um, probably there would be a line for where it's okay
to do what he did or what he did. If Casey Tron had literally
sent the skulls to him, if Casey Tron had said, "I want you guys
to go harass Ethan." And like or if she'd like been like publishing
his docs, if she'd been doing something like totally crazy, right?
Like there's something where maybe suing her for this might make
some sense that she could have acted so disgusting, right? I
don't think extracting the apologies for the other thing makes
sense, but you could just sue her and and take your money and
do whatever and off, right? But it's clear that Ethan I still
think it would be weird to like Yeah. Then it would just be you'd
have to I think to do this you'd have to be willing to go all
the way with the lawsuit. And I think Ethan had no desire to
do that truly. I think he wanted to just extract apologies for
other stuff which is weird. >> Okay. So then what's the
lie she's >> Um again I don't have specifics on mind but
if I know what these uh people
[clears throat] on that side of things believe.
For one, when they use the word Zionist, a lot of the times it
has the uh implicit >> Yeah. Welcome to the club. Welcome
to the Welcome to the club of being a liberal in America in the
current era.
Everyone who's a liberal gets this accusation. I get the accusation.
>> I have lefties being like, "You're not condemning the
genocide hard enough." Names will go unmentioned.
>> So, so this is not a particular Ethan issue. anyone
who is who is like kind of like oh I don't really want to talk
about it or I guess it's a genocide the the like they'll
>> well he can and he did right uh wait are you saying
I somebody was asking for where I would allow it was a hypothetical
on what I would allow obviously he can do it like I'm not I'm
not denying if you thought I was just going no reality is real
it isn't real it's actually all fake this didn't actually happen
if you thought that's what I was saying that would be really
silly but I I didn't do that they'll get they'll go after everyone.
So this is not a basis to this is not [__] this is
the kind of derangement that we see from lefties all the time
on certain they go crazy on this stuff.
>> Have you seen evidence suggesting that Ethan sent the
skulls to himself? It was posted by bad empanada but it seemed
legit. No, I don't believe that happened. Um I if there was compel
here's the thing. If there was compelling information on that
front I do believe I am in a circle of people where I would learn
about that very quickly and I would see it and be aware of it.
I'm sorry. It just It seems very unlikely to me. Um it's possible.
It's possible, but I doubt it. I feel like if it was compelling
and believable, right,
it's a hoax. JC is a fool. I literally just said I don't believe
it. You Kathy, are you are you deaf and dumb in addition to being
a white person who pretends to be an Indian? Jesus Christ. it
agreed that there is a general sense of craziness that is undirected
that is just sort of diffuse and it targets anyone who's who's
a liberal who's not a >> yeah welcome to the club there's
no particular agree >> okay I I at some point like uh Jesus
cow you got to go for more than 5 minutes this time no more posting
pictures no more posting degenerate emotes in my chat sorry you
can take another five minutes out off stop here's incline on
that front >> but no no no except But there is I don't
know how much
by by bad empanada
specific stuff from the leftover.
>> Dude, I actually just yelled at Kathy and then I lost
my place. So Kathy won a little bit. >> Agreed. There is
a general sense of craziness that is undirected that is just
sort of diffuse and it targets anyone who's who's a who's a liberal
who's a leftist. >> Yeah. Welcome to the club. There's
no particular agreement here for Ethan Klein on that front. >> But
no no no. Except there is. I don't know how much >> by
who?
[laughter]
>> Pisco's like, "Okay, totally insane people say that
I'm like a Zionist and can't really prove it and okay, like I
don't really care. It's whatever. Who cares?" Right? And this
guy's like, "No, I think uh I think we should sue and kill these
people. I think we should sue them and take their families houses
away. Okay. I think we should totally do that." Okay. What? What?
By by by bada
but by whoific
>> I'm going to go ahead and say it. Okay.
There is no number of YouTube videos from badonado that you could
watch. Okay. That would make it okay to do what Ethan did. Um
that would make it okay for him to like try to compel speech
and get Casey to concede on any number of random drama issues.
apologize for that's totally unrelated to the copyright case.
There's nothing that makes that total that total hostage video,
the beheading video, okay? In my opinion, there's nothing she
could have done. She could have watched every single video in
the Bad Empta library on stream and I still wouldn't go, "Oh
yeah, take her house away." Unless she Unless she's willing to
dance around for you and say, "I'm a little piggy" repeatedly.
Take her house away. Nope.
>> I who? >> Until until today. >> Yeah, but
but who specific
>> who is doing this stuff >> noted campaign of harassment
that is that is above what even like above what you get above
what pride hutch gets and >> the z the zogbot is just he's
bot out okay he's just he's totally he's glitched he's looping
he's just talking totally goes I guess at some point the cognitive
dissonance every single time you say hey could you just explain
why you think this every single time you do that eventually when
he realizes he can't explain anything he just keeps saying the
script cuz he realizes if if he lets Pisco ask why do you think
that he's going to look like a total re again so he just keeps
going through the script instead of actually responding to >> directed
and had specific people ring of people who were organizing it
behind the >> this is what I've heard I've heard >> it's
not it's not like just the sort of diffuse sort of wacky leftism
that hits >> This is This is what I've heard. I've heard
things like someone commented on Ela like a tattoo or something
or someone's tattoo and like basically called her horrible names.
Horrible, right? I I don't think that you should be doing this
this kind of stuff and like attacking people like that. And I
think you should be more respectful, whatever. I guess although
I'm not as I'm not very respectful to MAGA people. I'm just going
to say it. Um so, you know, your mindless may vary on that stuff
and especially now in the given age when I do believe that Israel
is committing a genocide. I do believe that. Um, I I'm just telling
you what, you know, my thoughts are that, you know, I probably
wouldn't do that. Like go after the tattoos. And >> I just
want to say I totally disavow
any person on the internet who says Ela Klein represents office
furniture. I disavow these comments in the strongest possible
terms. Okay. I just totally totally uncalled for to say that
her stretching resembles office furniture. It's completely disrespectful.
It's completely uncalled for. It's totally disgusting. It's reprehensible.
Stop doing it. is a little tasteless to me, but that might not
be the >> What does it mean? It means that she resembles
office furniture where when she tries to stretch her work out,
okay, she's like the tin man. She She looks like a desk. Okay,
that's what it means. I think that's what other people say when
they're totally disgusting and gross and and objectifying. Literally
objectifying Ela Klein. Okay. Turning her into an object like
a desk. >> What the Anyway, that's what I heard. Is there
any evidence in case you run into that attack? Like >> they're
looking for
>> Is there any evidence she was involved? >> I have
on hand.
>> As you sit here, any evidence that she lied about Ethan?
Maybe she did, but but you you certainly don't remember >> that
I have on hand. No. No. >> Any evidence that she's involved
with the skull?
>> Any evidence she's involved? Any evidence that she's
involved? Wait, wait, let's keep going. Any evidence she's involved
in the CBS call? >> Okay. Okay.
>> Any evidence that uh that she has >> We can keep
going. I don't say no to
>> These people will literally go on a stream. They'll
be like, "Here's a totally here's an accusation that I says that
I say, sorry, that I says. Here's an accusation that I think
makes it totally okay to dehumanize this person to try to destroy
their life, to try to totally crush them." Okay. Do I know that
that accusation is correct? No. No. I'm I I'm totally advocating
for doxing, suing, destroying the lives of these people on the
basis of no information.
I just some streamer told me it was okay.
Bro, shut the entire political streaming space down till we can
figure out what the hell is going on. What the are these people
on? What are they smoking? What are they huffing? I need to know
cuz it needs to be taken off the market. Okay. Holy sh Yeah,
I think this person deserved like total life ruination unless
they were willing to kneel completely because she participated
in something. What was that? I don't know. I I was told that
she deserves it. Okay, good for you. Go sit in the corner and
never call into a stream again. >> Evidence of she has
done all I will say. >> The thing is you have you entered
this you entered this conver this is why I'm saying it because
I'm not because that evidence maybe isn't there. It could be
>> Um dung devil if this was all he was doing. If this
was all he was doing it was just trying to protect his copyright,
right? If he wasn't this is totally fine except for the apology
video, right?
Except it's totally disgusting, degenerate,
spineless behavior to try to to try to make somebody apologize
for other drama, other things they've said on the internet. Just
get concessions about copyright. Just if it's about copyright,
just make it about copyright. I think this is and and there's
no legal thing against this. Apparently, you know, you could
you could sue somebody for copyright and get them to dance in
a circle like she like you did to Casey Tron. Make her say, "I'm
a little piggy. I'm a little piggy. I'm Casey Tron and I'm a
little piggy. Okay, that's what that's what he did essentially.
And everybody's like, "That's so cool that he did that." It's
total loser behavior. He's a totally loser. He has no business
giving his opinion online. He has no business commenting on other
people's [__] He has no business making fun of other
people on the internet. He is the biggest loser on the internet,
bar none. It's not close. And until people are willing to admit
this, I'm going to keep saying it. Thank you. Thank you. and
some someone could present it to me. I'm telling you it hasn't
been presented to me of that case specifically maybe other people
and certainly like bad empanada or the people who did the specific
acts that we're talking about certainly culpability whatever
I'm just wondering in your mind because you came in here confident
that this was justified because
um of the kind of things that like uh lonerbox is saying that
there are sometimes we have certain people who are beyond the
pale and they need to be dealt with in a hard hard way and I'm
asking if Casey Tron is one such person
>> not okay so that's my point I'm not
The whole point of the call is the guy has been convinced at
one point of Casey sins, but once asked, he'll refer to remembering
being convinced once, but cannot explain uh explain right now
how he knows. No, that's totally fine. Hold on. Hold on. Hold
on. It's totally fine to say that and acknowledge it. But that's
not what he did. Lj b a k s w y g r n s zn. Okay, that's not
what he's doing. What he did first was he came in and said it
was true. So he was he was speaking with the level of conviction
he had at the time he was convinced without being able to remember
anything. Okay? And he didn't come in and say I don't no no hold
on I'm just saying he didn't come in and say I don't remember
why but I remember being convinced of this. Do you know why people
say it? He didn't approach it with any intellectual humili intellectual
humility. He approached it saying no this is actually the way
it is. And I'm saying the world where you can take the opinion
of a streamer without any of the underlying opinion understanding
zero. I'm saying zero and you cannot and you you cannot explain
anything. You go on a stream and you say this is the way it is.
From that point on, you like actually should be chemically castrated.
Okay, get you get that person. I mean, that person's almost certainly
already removed themselves from the gene pool, but you need to
be out. Okay, humanity needs less of you. Whatever you are, humanity
doesn't need you anymore. Okay, we we're past that. You are the
exact kind of Trumpesque person. You're a Trump voter that happens
to be in a blue space right now. Okay? You are just one of these
Trumpcoded voters. Get the out. Don't have kids. Please stop.
Just stop life. Okay? Stop everything right now. >> That
she is necessarily one such person.
But her proximity
is sign to the people who are is at the very least
might justify targeting her in >> proximity. So on on that
>> Listen guy, there are no innocents in Palestine. There
are no innocents in Gaza. Everybody's complicit. Listen, Coy,
everybody's complicit in Gaza
>> on that view. >> Proximity in the sense that
>> you can't you actually you actually can't make it up.
You literally can't make it up. It's so
crazy >> on that view.
on that view >> proximity in the sense that in the sense
>> it it doesn't even necessarily need to be friendship.
I mean for example let's say you had a creator who uh never met
Nick Fuentes never talked to him never
texted him yet he was supporting him using the same rhetoric
uh saying I love him using the same uh lies. Hey Pisco, don't
you think like speech requires life ruination? Don't you think
that like saying things that aren't even defamatory because you
won't actually file a defamation case? Don't you think that like
if you have another way of extracting concessions in something,
if you want to say somebody's defaming you and you want them
to agree they're defaming you, then just sue them for something
else and make a condition of letting the lawsuit go that they
admit to the defamation. They admit they were lying. Yeah. Yeah.
You're scripting it. You're saying they have to say it, right?
But hey, that's that's just the way it Sorry. That's just the
way it is, man. That's just the way it is. >> I would I
would see it as acceptable. >> That's totally >> the
sort of same gor.
>> So the issue is with the Caseyron thing, you are giving
the moral condemnation of that you would give to bad empanada
for advocating for all of these things, for actually doxing people,
right? actually doxing people for doing the the lion's den tweet
or whatever, right? That's that's what you're doing. You're you're
taking that mor level of moral condemnation. This person anything
done to this person is morally justifiable. You're attaching
it to Caseyron when she's done none of those things. That is
the problem. That is collective guilt, my friend. That is there
are no innocents in Gaza. That is we'll shut the water off and
those people. Who cares? That's what that is. Do you understand
that? That's totally deranged. That's totally insane. Nobody
believes that if you unpack it even a tiny bit. My skitso theory
skills are telling me this is just an anti- loader box op. Dude,
there's no way I have to. If Loader Box was saying anything akin
to this, I got to see it. I got to see it. Can we find it? Can
we find it anywhere? I >> I have this text between them
right here. I don't have to point to that. I can point to the
>> Is this a standard you would apply? Is this a standard
you would apply to people you like?
like, "Oh, I'm going to go after Loner Box because he associates
with such and such and therefore
>> like like okay uh
it's funny that he brought up isn't it kind of funny? Isn't it
a little bit comical that he brought up Fentes as the example
for hey if you like talk about Fentes you talk to Fentes then
and technically he said spew the same rhetoric. Although
again
I don't know that Casey Tron spews the same rhetoric as somebody
like Badam Panata. It's like vaguely on that side not liking
Ethan. It's like, oh, anybody who doesn't like Ethan, this is
again, it's the exact same abstract concept. Um, what's the thing
that connects all of these people that that Destiny's doxing?
Oh, they don't like Destiny,
right? That's the thing that connects them. Have they done the
same actions? No. Do they believe the same things? No. Do they
have anything similar at all? Yeah, they kind of like don't like
Destiny and the way he's acting. Yep, that's it. What? What's
the similarity between Caseyron and bad empanada? Um, they basically
just don't like Ethan and the way he's acting. Oh, well, guess
what? Disliking Ethan the way he's acting. That means you're
bad empanada. That means we get to you. Okay, good luck.
Guess you shouldn't have hated Ethan. Guess you shouldn't have
disliked Ethan. Get the out of your house or get on your knees
and suck Ethan's. Now, >> I'm going to tar him with whatever
negative person that person did. Would you accept that? I would
be more concerned if he used the same sort of rhetoric and the
same lies.
>> Actually, not liking Ethan Klein. Yeah, that that gets
you put in a gas chamber. Okay, you dislike Ethan Klein. Uh,
get them on the train. Get them sent to Awitz. Okay.
Where's Where's my Where's my Fortnite clip? Okay. Where's my
Where's my Fortnite clip? >> I'm sending these kids to
Ashwitz.
>> Thank you, Mr. Porto. >> You haven't grounded
that out. >> Not Not merely association. I'm talking >> participation,
right? Right. So, if you participate Yeah. I mean, okay, sure.
But you're
>> um I broadly agree with this, Valpal. I would just say
whatever this analogy is right here, if L I see the thing I think
that happened is is Loner Box probably had something way more
nuanced than this. Like way way more nuanced than this. Okay.
And he probably said something kind of little bit like this.
A little bit a tiny bit like this. But it wasn't really that
close. And this guy heard it and was like, "Oh, I know how I
can like work this into other things, I think." And this guy
did his own little twist on it. And it's a totally Nobody should
have let him cook, okay? He was like, "Let me get in the kitchen
here." And he walked up to the stew and he unccorked the salt.
He unscrewed the top of the salt and just dumped the whole thing
in the stew. Okay? Never let this guy cook again. He ruined it
entirely. Whatever idea could have been there has been destroyed.
And he showed up to this stream. He was like, "Yeah, actually,
uh, collective guilt is totally a cool thing." Yeah, everybody
in Gaza is guilty. Just sticking to his Israel analogy which
he went with for some reason. >> Saying specifically, you
don't have proof of that, right?
>> What has Bad Padata done that's crazy? He's just doxes
people a lot. Yeah, he's just doxed a lot of people and intentionally
like threatens to dox people. He's like he's like what Destiny
is now, right? He's just been he's like Destiny.
Um him him and Destiny are basically like the same guy
like 100%.
>> Not on hand. Okay. >> Yes. I have I have my impressions
of the >> which listen I I don't understand how DJers think
that's a problem. What is their problem with bad empanada? Copyright
infringement, intellectual property theft. What's the What's
the >> Okay, let's talk about uh Denim. >> I feel
like Dan equals Bad Panata. Nope. Nope. Destiny is bad and panata
here. Dan is not bad and panata. No, no, no, no. Desi is a way
better analog because Bad Panata publishes the docs himself.
Dan goes through proxies. Okay. Bad Panata does it himself. Destin
himself. They're the same. They're equal. >> All right.
Denims. What's the evidence that denims? >> Collective
punishment, not guilt. Ah, collective guilt. Still the same thing.
Yeah,
there's no allegations about I I'm unaware of any allegations
about bad empanada. Unless they're coming from not >> deserving
of your words, dirty trick.
>> Um, as far as denims goes, I don't Okay, I don't on
hand have any evidence for anything that I can point to in specifics.
How how can you be sure that they deserve it then? How can you
sure that if you can't >> because because I have my because
man, I'm I'm old. I haven't I I don't remember all this drama
stuff. I've seen videos that have convinced me of that. And that's
what stuck in my mind is the fact that they're bad people who
participated in this overall campaign. Not necessarily they did
it because on this day, June 19th, they said this and this and
this.
I can surely go look them up if I feel like it. if I really have
to and I can come back with receipts,
I just have the impressions that have been left on me.
>> I mean, I think you're
>> that's a better place to leave it that but I'm saying
that this guy what should have happened. Okay. What everybody
agrees that like the the level of intellectual humility you have
should be commensurate with the amount of knowledge you have.
So basically, if you're like, "Well, I don't really remember,
but I feel this way." If you represent it that way from the beginning,
then nobody has a problem, right? You could come in and say that
like, "Hey man, I just wanted to say like it would be super to
do this." And it would be embarrassing on a different in a different
way, but it would be so much more honest that I wouldn't hate
the person, right? If he came in was like, "Man, I don't remember
for sure, but I like I seem to remember being convinced that
Casey Tron really deserved this." And like I can't even put into
words.
I can't even like come up with an example, but I really think
she did deserve it. Like I that's what my that's what I feel,
but I can't prove it. Do you remember what she did? Like I cuz
I really thought she deserved this and now I don't know, right?
If you come in and done that, which would be I don't know why
you're calling in then, but why?
Nobody would be angry at you in the same way that like I'm annoyed
now, right? It's not like totally weird, totally disgusting behavior.
I'm glad that listen, I'm just glad that Pisco has said that
Destiny's allegations against my community without evidence.
When Pisco said Destiny is a totally disgusting loser who's made
up these allegations with no evidence and anybody propagating
that is also a disgusting [__] loser, I had to clap.
Okay, I had to clap for that. It was really cool that Pisco had
to point out how disgusting this cope is and how degenerate the
act is. Right. Okay. You You're going to go around and spread
some allegation with no proof. You have no idea why you believe
it. Yeah, you're you're a loser. You should feel bad. You should
How dare you, sir? How dare you? He Pisco. Hit her with the hit
him with the Greta Thunberg. Okay. How dare you? How dare you
come up my stream and say these things.
Thank you, Pisco. Thank >> And then maybe you won't be
convinced without specifics, in which case maybe I'll try to
round some up. But uh >> but just so we're clear, that's
it's the exact same thing. And for me, you will not be able to
prove that I deserve my community getting docked. So, you won't
be able to do it. Destiny tries to do it. I think he took he
took emails of I I'm trying to find the worst emails from Cybo.
Okay. There's no way. I I got a list from somebody. There's no
way that Destiny's saying. Maybe that'll be content for tomorrow
is I'll I'll go through this after stream and I'll try to see
exactly what Cyber said and I'll figure it out and we'll maybe
cover that tomorrow. We'll see what the threats the quote unquote
threats are. Okay.
And again, I've already said I think probably from what I remember
the cyber emails were
what him him saying you should contact like Joan Peters or something
and but I don't know where the threats are. I I hope I hope I
see them just cuz I I fully believe that there's no way Destiny
could just lie entirely about what's in those emails and people
would just believe it, right? I as far as the denim thing goes,
I don't have anything specific in mind that I can point to specifically,
but I can say I am pretty sure I remember she may have been pretty
closely connected to the CPS or either the CPS thing or I think
the CPS thing. How in the sense that one can
Okay, so
that's been massively overblown and there was like an edited
clip that helped it get massively overblown and then people pretended
that it wasn't massively overblown because of the edited clip
of the stuff. Okay. But it was it's how everybody perceived it.
And whenever you con whenever you uh what would you say? Whenever
you uh present it to somebody who's like impartial who's seen
the stuff from before, they go, "Whoa, that clip was edited.
That's not the whole chat." I thought it was the whole chat the
whole time only talking about CPS and like dog and gardia and
all this, right? And it's like, "No, that's a there's an edited
clip that shows that." Um
damn. Yeah.
He has no idea where the CPS call came from. Yeah. Nobody has
any idea where the CPS call came from. And I think that's bad
that the CPS call happened.
But by the way, if Hassan came out when that CPS call happened,
Hassan came out and said, "Whoa, that's crazy, guys. Ethan's
a good parent. I don't care what else is going on. Ethan's a
good parent." Did any single one of them give Hassan an ounce
of credit for that? Like a tiny a millimeter of credit for that.
Did a single person go, "Oh, Hassan did the right thing. I'm
going to shout that out. I'm going to say Hassan did the right
thing. That's really cool. Hassan. Nope. Nope. They they just
went back the next day and they're like, "How can we make Hassan
look bad again?"
And me, for me personally, I just be like, "You know what? He's
going to do it to himself. Give him a couple weeks. He'll figure
it out. Don't don't try to force it, okay? It'll happen naturally."
That's like the thing is all these people, it's like the the
Hassan is bad industry, the cottage Hassan is bad industry is
like suffering from trying to make a big deal out of everything.
And so they end up handing Hassan W's. You just let Hassan blow
up organically. He'll figure it out. He can figure it out all
the time. Wait, Hassan really did that. Yeah. Hassan came out
was like, "No, Ethan's a good dad. Don't say that." Right. It's
You can't Don't be calling CPS. I He came out and denounced it.
I'm positive that this happened. Yeah. Anyway, but nobody cares.
Nobody cares cuz they're not actually engaging. >> point
to her making the call or telling someone to make >> What's
the best evidence that she's connected to? Fine. >> What's
the best evidence that she
>> She says some of the same things. Like what? Like what
does she say? What are the same things? Uh like Ethan sucks and
Ethan fed his dog cheese. Okay. Did Ethan feed his dog cheese?
Yeah, but it's up that they say it. Okay, cool. Cool. Uh that's
fantastic. It was I think it was that she amplified the lie and
said someone should call CPS or something like that and then
shortly >> so so you're asserting you're asserting that
it's your belief that Denim said >> dude this GUY'S GOT
TO GET OUT OF THE CALL JEDI YOU KEEP MAKING THINGS UP I KNOW
OR I don't know maybe she did I that was my example was like
did she at least say like he totally deserved it that's still
not making it happen by the way that's still not her being responsible
for it happening
right that's totally different saying she deserved it is totally
It's still reprehensible though. You don't I for me personally
that's like basically like a valing swatting in a way, right?
It's I don't you don't say people deserve it even it's you don't
say it. Okay. >> Said that this ought in other words that
she believes it's good if someone does X that is call CPS on
and that you think that she said that. >> I might be mistaken.
It's one of them that did. I'm just
I'm just throwing out ideas here, guys. I'm just throwing out
ideas. I think maybe Caseyron did X or Y or Zed. I just think
that maybe somebody did like X, Y, or Z, you know? I think maybe
that might have happened. Maybe.
dude. These people suck. >> So, I'm I don't want to I'm
not 100% coughing on that, but I'll see like I'm probably 70%.
Yeah. And and >> you know, from what I know, I think Ethan
backal I'm pretty sure Ethan backed away from that claim >> in
a in a video. >> Oh, okay. Well, >> you see, hold
on. I Dude, this is why I got to get away from the Destiny stuff.
You see how like depressing the Destiny content is to do like
in so many ways. This is sort of this is a Jason, so it's not
totally different, but holy, at least I'm not like It's like
so much more fun. It's just more fun. Okay. And I could even
tie it back to the Dusty stuff tangibly, by the way. It's like
the same group of people operating the same way, same exact standard
they've set. That's totally insane. You can't apply anywhere
else. Everybody in liberal societies broadly agreed that this
is not the way you handle things. You don't do collective guilt.
You don't do collective punishment. But these guys, no, they're
all for it. They're all for it. Okay. Well, then maybe you did.
And then in which case, >> that's fine. I mean, that's
I look and I I agree. Even if she said someone ought to do that,
that is not necessarily legally wrong. >> I heard bad empanada
say that.
>> Yeah, of course. But I mean, everyone agrees he's a
bit of a scumbag like a >> Yeah, a bit of a scumbag. That's
where all of your moral moral condemnation comes from is bad
and empanada. You take the things that people have said or or
the things bad has done or said and you apply the same level
of moral outrage and moral condemnation to people who aren't
doing anything remotely like that because somebody told you you
could
because e because
ah I just bit my tongue because
because
might have said at some point I don't really feel bad about Ethan
Klein getting uh CPS called on him. There was dog [__]
on the floor.
So, she deserves every the all the moral condemnation for everything
bad and has ever done. That's okay. And she deserves her life
ruined. She deserves her life ruined or her pride shattered.
One of the two.
Okay. I I honestly I don't even care if you shatter her pride
via content. You want to just constantly like Asen Gold took
the right approach, right? Asenold didn't get latigious. Asenold
went I'm a [__] on this person every day. this person.
Okay,
guess what? That's the game. That's the game, dog. And when you're
a significantly worse person than Asmin Gold and you don't think
about ending it, I don't know. I What are we even doing here
as humanity? Okay. You're like a significantly worse human being
than Asmin Gold. What am I supposed to say? What am I supposed
to do about that? I don't know.
>> He didn't use a dirty trick on bad empanada. He didn't
use what on bad empanada. He used it on Casey Tron denims and
these people. Now, maybe it's deserved. I'm just asking for the
proof.
Yeah, bad pad. I would have been happy if he did, but obviously
given venue,
it's probably not feasible. >> Yeah, if you can't if you
if you can't sue the right targets,
you shouldn't sue at all. Right. Like if if that's now, if you
if you were honest
>> go ahead. >> Alternatively, I'll put this down.
>> No, I had to stop the rocket attacks. The rocket attacks
being saying mean things about me. How am I going to stop the
rocket attacks? a totally unrelated lawsuit.
Why? Why can't if they're all lies, if they're all just totaling
lies, why can't you sue the people for them directly? Why can't
you make them like why can't you send them a cease and desist
and make them stop saying them? Uh well, isn't there like a forum
for that? Isn't there a venue for that? Like, if somebody's lying
about you, isn't there a venue to address that through the legal
system? No. No. I just I have to use copyright to do it. Okay.
If you can't see the exact right targets would be which would
be in my mind the snark mods and banana panada and maybe a few
people who I can't think of off
>> It might be acceptable instrumentally to send a
>> Nicholas Dioro and his rhetoric have been disastrous
for the human race. Okay. The entire comedy commentary space.
I feel like I feel like I just got to say it. Okay. This guy
definitely this guy definitely going to be a Nicholas Dioro viewer.
They're drafting off the same talking points is so gross, man.
Come on, dude.
>> So to speak, to go after lieutenants, to go after periphery.
>> Yeah, even if they don't necessarily specifically, [laughter]
>> dude. Uh, yeah. No, this is this is I listen, I can't
find any crimes from these people that deserve getting drone
struck, so we're going to drone strike them anyway. Listen, I
have a feeling I just have a feeling. Okay,
listen. If you find out that this person wasn't related to, then
you can you can sanction me. You can court marshall me after.
Okay, I'm just going to take the shot. I'm just going to drop
the bomb. If you find out that they weren't related to Well,
well, you know, that's just one more dead Palestinian on the
pile. What is it? What is it to anybody
>> Lieutenants implies agency. Implies allegiance and a
common purpose, right? A lieutenant is someone who is an agent
of a principle, maybe a general or commander chief. >> Sure.
And this whole time I've said there's like a loose sort of confederacy.
Not one that I could say, "Hey, here's the command structure
or here are the specific test. Hey, go do this." But there's
a clear sort of social millu,
similar messages, similar lives, similar watchers that watch
the same things. You know, they sort of all sort of crowd in
the same space. >> And I think a lot of the big figures
in that space are fair game in my in my >> Okay. for this
sort of dirty trick. >> I'll give you the last word, but
the the final question I have for you that other people and
>> so that's that's where Pisco has to say like you're
actually a disgusting loser. Like you basically sat here, you
got dogwalked through how none of your beliefs are grounded in
any reality. Like they're not grounded in anything you can state
and then at the very end you go, "But I still basically believe
everything I believed before." You watch the Golem reset in real
time. You actually got to see it. Here it is for everybody. Here's
the column resetting in real time.
It's happened. We just watched it occur.
Um, I know I just totally embarrassed myself on stream, but I'm
going to keep believing everything I believe now. I'm not going
to do any introspection. I'm not going to do any self work, any
self-healing. I'm I'm just going to keep doing the thing I do.
I'm going to propagate misery in the world cuz that's who I am
>> Great. Cool. >> I do appreciate your comments.
The final question I have for you is, have you lowered your level
of confidence that they deserved it after this conversation?
>> Okay, I'll answer that directly. No. And
>> dude, no shot. Oh, get me out. Get me out. Get me out.
Get me out. Get me out. Get me out. Thank god the stream's at
zero. I can't go a lot longer. Okay. Holy [__] >> I'm
confident in my assessment of the stuff I have seen. And in fact,
you know, just Bro,
bro, what? What the [__] These people have will have
the audacity, by the way, the people who are like in this space,
they'll have the a to make fun of religious people. They'll show
up, they'll do this, and then they'll go, "Oh, at least I don't
believe in magical sky daddy. [laughter]
These people are out of their minds. I don't know. I don't know
what else to say, man. It's so over. Holy shit." >> Because
I'm a bored kind of person. I'll go and look for some specifics
that will
>> hopefully back up. But uh but in my mind
>> this is and >> this is more or less precisely
why I have no problem with religion because basically every everybody
operates on religion. They've just picked different religions,
okay? Politics become a religion. I'm not going to go into that
whole thing about how that's like deep or something. It's not.
It's just kind of what happened. Okay? Like it's it's just they're
obviously just religious. They're religiously tied to an influencer.
Okay. >> This could be my final word or whatever. uh what
serves as
>> necessary [clears throat] or or actually sufficient
evidence for me to to come to this is not necessarily going to
be one or two sort of
very damning comments or screenshots that are like that you can
admit in court.
>> It would be um >> kind of like hints of stuff
and uh vague
>> Well, yeah. For me, if someone is on certain subs, comments
on certain
Dude, dude, dude, dude, dude. You cannot. Oh my goodness. Uh,
I'm gonna have to actually at this guy in Lerbox's Discord. If
he's there, please be there.
>> Oh, come on.
>> Sorry. I said to write up a little message to this guy
in Litterbox's Discord. Just uh I had to throw that in there
cuz holy [__] Just told it's like the most embarrassing
thing I've ever
>> This is rough. This is rough. This is rough to watch.
>> Not not not by itself. I'm talking about if you have
a lot of things going together, but there might not be any necessary
or sufficient clause. It might be a family resemblance sort of
idea like Vickenstein, you know, like >> sounds like collective
>> trying to define the word. >> Well, it it's more
like defining the word game. There's no necessary sufficient
definition for the word game. >> Oh, game. >> Game
game. >> Like what's a game? You cannot think of a a set
of necess >> I've heard life is a game >> in sufficient
conditions because there'll always be something. >> Yeah.
No, I I mean I I agree with that.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And so I think when you think of the I don't
think there's a necessary and sufficient sort of conditions I
can list for who deserves to be targeted here. It's more of a
>> But that's not what I'm asking for. I'm asking involved.
>> Well, that's not what I'm asking for you to specifically
delineate. It's just like is it enough to >> guys and and
their version of their like targeting parameters or whatever
their like um their go parameters what is it called like their
collateral calculations they do for this guy you don't need any
to catch anybody in it that is actually related to the primary
bad actors right so bad empanidata is the guy he hates and he
or and snark are the is the one he hates like this snark subreddit
or something you don't need any evidence of Casey Tron participating
in any of the things they've done. You just need her like occasionally
reading that subreddit or something, getting like a somebody
in her chat who provides like a clip from that subreddit. And
now she's a valid target. Okay, this is like saying if you're
in Gaza and you wear a flag in any way you have anything in your
house, you're a valid military target when it's the government.
Are you serious,
bro? to use the same language and hang out in the same spaces
as people who have wronged someone else. >> Well, among
other things, uh to be >> so by so Pisco now discovering
if you guys don't remember, okay, if you don't remember the Queenman
response, okay, this is the the natural response to the Willy
Mack video. I guess the standard you've laid out here is that
being in a community with somebody who does something that you
feel is morally reprehensible or having any tangential contact
with them means you yourself are subject to their treatment like
how how anybody in that community would be sorry how anybody
who doesn't like that community or [clears throat] that person
would treat them. Right? So the worst actor in that community,
you're now responsible for everything they do. We're going to
have that that exact idea of collective punishment. That's what
you've laid out here is collective punishment. on a on a grand
scale on the internet. So you've got somebody who doxes now everybody
who who's ever talked to that person is a doxer and I could treat
them like a doxer. They get the same moral consideration.
Absolutely wild concept for somebody who claims they believe
in democracy. Hey, guess what? I heard Trump believes in something
like that. Hey, if you're coming from Venezuela, you got a boat.
Uh, I think you're a narcotics trafficker and I'm going to treat
you like a narcotics trafficker. Congratulations, guys. You just
justified the whole naroterrorism angle in the Caribbean. Okay,
congratulations.
Well done. And then when I say these people are like MAGA, they
get offended.
Shut up.
I need to crib this from Pisco. Okay. How dare you? How dare
you
figure
>> uh Well, yeah, cuz I have other categories that I didn't
get to other other conditions like to to be a significant enough
figure in that space. I think media figures in particular
um who have followings that by itself is gives more cause. Um
I I mean there's a number of things but I think I think he's
in
>> unfortunately we've got another noticer here. This this
young presumably okay not for sure but presumably fellow has
a take in the chat.
I wonder where he got this novel perspective from. Quote unquote
lurbox viewer. Huh. This young man, I assume I can only assume
from the name and the the symbol. Okay. Looks kind of like Illuminati
eye. Seems like he's involved with some conspiracies. Possibly
some some back some back alley snarking. Okay. Seems like a fellow.
He has a not he has a crazy idea that this guy might not be a
loner box viewer. He might get some ideas on collective punishment
from other streamers. Wow. Cool. Very cool. Very neat. >> Kind
of a battle. And if I were in the same position, I would want
to take some scalps to deter others. Be like, "Look, I'll play
dirty, too, cuz they've been >> deter from what
>> from harassing.
If they just stop, you know, or
>> it's literally if you Destiny, accuse me of being part
of a Kiwi Farm Starker Queen J Cabal, working behind the scenes
to turn Pisco against him because I agreed Pis with Pisco more
than him in a spite driven debate." Yes. This is true.
Unfortunately, dude, it's just obvious, right? It's just obvious
on its face what's going on. >> Back off. I realize, hey,
I might get in some deep [__] if I uh >> keep
going down this road. >> He's really ligious. He's going
to me up. I better just back off,
>> you know.
>> Uh
this this guy just admitted that the whole reason Ethan is doing
this is to chill criticism against him. Okay, he's going to say,
"No, chill." like chill like participating in any space that's
like overly negative of him. That's the same thing. It's the
same thing. The line can be drawn anywhere. You don't give actual
discernable criteria at all. Okay, [__] off, man.
>> That's sufficient for me to >> Dude, this is this
is so much worse than what I expected. I knew this could be bad.
I knew some of these people were stupid. By the way, this is
exactly what Lost Harrison looks like every time he debates this
too about my Discord. It's all of these people. And I hate to
say it, but they all go watch the same streams that refuse to
condemn certain people. Very interesting. >> Because of
>> or sorry, not certain people, not certain people, certain
actions. Okay. Like the doxing.
I How many streamers have have spoken up? I just I I'm curious.
Has anybody gone like, "Oh, this Supreme thing, that's like the
line for me. Somebody done that? Is there a person who's done
that?
This esports Batman thing? That's actually the line for me?"
No. Nobody. Nobody out here doing it. Okay, that's fine. the
extent that they've done. >> Ah, okay. I feel I feel refreshed
on this suddenly. Suddenly, I feel refreshed like, hey, maybe
I should go and jump back into some of this stuff. >> Harassment
campaign.
>> Hey, I I super appreciate your your contributions and
uh maybe we can talk
>> All right.
his contributions being a total [__] who showed up
said expressed a strong a weak opinion strongly held the opposite
of what you should have right he was like I kind of feel this
way and I'm positive that it's this way got totally blown out
had no examples couldn't even Pisco wasn't asking for videos
or clips Pisco was saying what what did she do the guy couldn't
name what she did at all he had no idea right
and then Pisco after after he's walked through this very silently
this is what blackfield killed me, too. I'd walk people through
stuff like very calmly, very respectfully, and it would have
no effect. They would reset immediately, right? This guy reset
before even leaving the VC. At least have the respect to say,
"No, Pisco, you helped me change my mind. No, Pisco, you changed
me a little bit. Not that much, but a little bit. Not that much,
but a little bit. Pisco, at least have the the I don't know,
the respect for Pisco to do that. Don't come in here be completely
incapable of expressing your opinion, right?
And then
co No, I haven't changed my opinion at all. No, you haven't changed
my opinion at all.
Why? Why? Why? Why? Why?
Why?
H my god.
I didn't read the chat messages at the end. I want to check this
one out real quick. Doesn't recall any specifics. Oh, no. Okay,
no, we're fine. Doesn't recall any specifics, but have a strong
conviction of what he believes is true and will go back to look
for it. Sounds like a recipe for motivated reasoning
Well, I actually found this one clip of her reading a snark thread,
and that means she deserves everything that happened. She's a
snarker. I've created this label. It's called Snark. And if you've
ever referenced something from this place, wait, does Ethan reference
stuff from here? Yeah, all the time. Yeah, all the time. He totally
does. Does Ethan reference things from other people's snark subreddits
or Kiwi Farms threads? Yeah, all the time. All the time. Wait,
so that means that Ethan probably has signed up for the exact
harassment that he's gotten. No. No. Not like that. No. Don't
Don't do collective guilt like that. Don't do collective punishment
LIKE THAT. NO. NOT to Ethan. Not the skulls. Not the sword. Not
CPS.
It's so
the only joy you can get from this is knowing that you can sit
here and call these people out for their totally
their totally un indefensible takes, their totally indefensible
positions and they'll never be able to fight back because they
have lost. They've lost entirely. They're wrong. Right? Some
small solace, I guess. Maybe not cold comfort really when they're
doxing everybody around you and trying to destroy your community.
But hey, you take what you can for a silver lining, boys. We'll
uh we'll be flipping this shortly. Okay, we'll be flipping this
God, these people suck.
People suck so